masha ammonia has misdemeanors on
catlantis of course Ali called upon to
see a perfect
I come from the south support you from a
poor family and from my parents was
already really tough to get me to go to
Lisbon for the university it was the
moment that my life changed forever
container he does in vilkin kenapa
doesn't become kenapa also don't
reproach desert his son lousy come to a
don't care it is any espanol is a
neologism italia kettle exact America
lament difficulty they also sent a
tragedy
and so it was like for two years very
tough because I could basically
understand but I could not express
myself and those kind of experiences in
life are so important because they craft
you as a person and I think that Erasmus
is more important because of that
because it actually changes you as a
person it's not about what you learn or
where you go to another university but
the experience that you cannot do in a
digital world I mean I always say that
you can digitalize everything but you
cannot digitalize the experience that
you're having here
[Music]
I still today when I come to my job
every day I feel that I'm not really
working I'm paying back what Europe did
for me
do it even if your parents tell you not
to do it even if your professors and
coaches tell you not to do it and you'll
earn much more than you can learn in a
course or studying or reading so do it
do it do it
[Music]
you